So let's look at what one memory bit
looks like in SRAM and DRAM technology.
The bit sits at the intersection of
a wordline that passes by many bits,
and the bitline that
also passes by many bits.
So memory is a matrix
of cells like this.
And DRAM will also have a wordline and
a bitline.
What the wordline does, is it controls
a transistor here that can open or
close itself to connect
the cell to the bitline.
So the idea is that,
if we want to access this cell,
we activate this wordline which
opens this transistor, and
now the memory cell is
connected to the bitline.
So if we want to write data, we put
the bitline at the value we want, and
the cell gets that value.
If we want to read the data,
we'll let go of the bitlines, and then
the cell here will get a new value on
the bitline, so we can sense what it is.
In SRAM, the actual memory cell
consists of two inverters.
Each inverter has two transistors,
that's how you build an inverter.
And the idea is that, if this is 1 here,
then this inverter flips it and
outputs a 0 here.
This other inverter flips that and
outputs 1 here, so
once we disconnect this transistor,
this cell will keep its value.
It's going to maintain a 0 here
because that 0 is inverted and
output is a 1 here,
which amplifies the 0 here, so
we have a feedback loop here that
keeps the data that we want.
So how to we write to this cell?
So if we try to put a 1 here, this
inverter here is working against us.
Because it sees a one,
it wants to output a zero.
And the answer to that,
is that this transistor here
connects this cell to the bit line.
If we put a stronger 1 here,
because these are small inverters,
we can defeat them, so
that even though this inverter is trying
to put a 0 here, we defeat it with a 1.
And then what happens is,
that now that this is a 1,
this inverter outputs a 0 here,
this inverter now starts outputting
a one, and the cell becomes a 1.
To make that easier, typically we
have two of these transistors and
two bit lines for the same cell
that have the opposite values.
So for this cell to become a 1,
we put 1 here and 0 here.
That puts a 1 here at the same
time when we are putting a 0 here.
So these are more easily defeated.
When we want to read, we can connect
both of them to the bit lines.
And if we wrote a 1 here, we will
have this one be 1, this one be 0.
So this line really
outputs the bit we want.
And this one just outputs the opposite
value of the bit we want.
By looking at the difference
between these bitlines,
we can more quickly detect
what the cell actually has.
As we said,
these are weak transistors here.
So once we connect this cell to
the bitlines, the bitline is long.
And in order to, for example,
raise the voltage on the bitline
to a value that corresponds to 1,
this transistor here are weak and
cannot pull it to 1 very fast.
They also will try to
lower this one down to 0,
and they may not be able
to do that very fast.
So at the other end here where we're
trying to detect what's in this cell,
instead of looking at when will this
cross a threshold between a 0 and a 1,
what we look at is in what direction
is the difference of these two going.
We make them, initially,
about halfway between 0 and 1.
We then activate the word line,
the cell now starts,
let's say, pulling this one up and
lowering this one down.
If we look at what's
the difference very quickly,
we'll detect that this one here,
because it's drawn towards 1,
is getting to be larger voltage
than the voltage on this one.
So we can now say that the cell had a 1
before it actually manages to pull this
fully to 1 and lower this fully to 0.